hey guys i'm ryan right and i'm gerry
today we're gonna check out the trailer
for how how is cool
good evening ladies and gentlemen
this is your guard speaking
welcome aboard in 23:59 service to each
spur displeased
does he take it please
such great night shouldn't one
surely there's a variety of characters
in this movie we see they're broken down
just outside each book is the train
broken down or not working two miles
walk before the tracks rule stay
together does either be problem
mr. train for a bear bait
damn vixen that looks cool that's our
those are off like oh one of these like
super serious [ __ ] boring or built
and then what's all that [ __ ] started
happening right when I saw this shot of
like that you see the werewolves foot
and the devour you someone like that
sounds like whoa [ __ ] this is creepy and
then after that it was like an intense
thrill ride I mean if the trailer is any
indication in the movie it seems like
one of those movies it will actually
take a little time to set up its story
to set up its characters you know give
you a good first act before getting
right to carnage and then the carnage
looks like it will be rewarded well yeah
and the werewolves don't look like
[ __ ] crazy CGI [ __ ] yeah I mean you
can tell some of them are enhanced but
it's just that it's like a family what
makes some of it is makeup some of its
enhancing that's the perfect way to sort
of marry the two together and it's an
interesting way to tell a werewolf story
you know like it's done like this could
have easily been they have to get off on
a train and then weird [ __ ] starts
happening in the woods or something
yeah but rather than that like they're
hiding on a train it's not operating in
the middle of nowhere it's cool it's a
cool like closed environment kind of
film that probably takes place in real
time you know yeah you know you know
werewolf scenario it's not far-fetched
to believe that you know uh a train
broke down in the woods like you take
trains for long distance trips you know
like and these are like these wolves
look scary hell yeah I do like I'm glad
to have a scary world or at least a
scary-looking werewolf movie again but
yeah it's been a while likes they stand
but they look like werewolves yeah yeah
it's been it's cool that we're getting
like werewolves kind of get their own
it's like stupid action flicks or
something these days you know well cuz
we've had a whole lot of like
underworlds and Twila nice yeah so it's
nice to have you know a formidable wears
like a fresh werewolf movie it really
does it actually very impressed with the
trailer like fresh but also kind of
classic you know
I know maybe a little bit of a return to
form for a werewolf cinema because that
first one the trailer started when they
were showing the different people I was
like oh yeah we got our variety of
personality so there is gonna be some
cliches all the different people who are
gonna bounce off the sides of this
division it looks great it looks really
entertaining looks very entertaining it
oh down so down rating time we will
definitely be there to check out how
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Jerry's play list reasons to
Jerry movie reviews and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where if we get enough followers product
placement help us out we it's so hard to
watch other people's content and review
it so it would be nice if we could get
some money on the side nice if we can
get somebody with a product to review us
it's like what is the Pepsi corporation
think about Ryan and chair Adam each
jazz hot ages hey been following you on
YouTube for a while love your reaction
videos why do I deserve a shout out
because I said so if you had a chance to
take one celebrity out who would be
who's a better singer between you and
Tyrone Agnes I also have a youtube
channel trying to become an Omega you
may be Omega prankster good for you man
if I have the chance to take one
celebrity out it would be Ryan Gosling
because Ryan Gosling well you know like
yeah you're gonna choose a woman sure
but then what if she's disappointing
you're gonna be like I should have gone
with like let's say I want she's now a
Portman that would be my top woman but
let's say I'm like always disappoint
with the sex and Natalie Portman
then I would be like I should have
[ __ ] Mila Kunis instead and then
but if it's a guy who you know will
deliver a guy hangout
different-different never never like
sucked a dick before but I'll suck Ryan
Gosling's dick sure who's a better
singer between you and Tyrone Magnus me
Jerry give me a song oh that one you
dance to strangers in the night two
lonely people we were strangers in the
night Frank Sinatra lyrics they were
strangers in the night